you
game on team light let's try Knight f3
to start alright let's go with d4
quick here how will black defend a6 c6
or takes
something else No
I'm gonna clean b3 Queen b3 knight c6 I
could also play Knight c3 and on D take
C play a four I don't want a week in my
be four square though uh-huh
okay well I think
starters definitely want my night out to
be a little bit careful I've done this
before Bishop f4 on my next move and
then there's D take C and if I'm
recapturing I'm dropping on b2
so I might have to be a little bit
cautious about bringing the bishop out
before resolving this tension here
between the pond so maybe I want to
consider c5 to give the Queen a kick I'm
fine with Queen takes Queen it gives my
queen some play and I think I'm gonna
run with that right now
hmm
um let's see
Oh the ratings aren't even showing up on
this game I don't know why huh see five
that's weird c5 and if Queen takes Queen
pawn takes of course night a six to here
is that going to be a bug
I'm going to still shoot for
okay 96 on 96 I think I'll play Brooke a
four just to stop night before okay
that's not being played
I'm gonna get my bishop outside here III
if my opponent isn't careful this pond
could get here okay I think it's best to
stop that knife from getting to be four
altogether I don't want to have any
worries of like Knights e2 or 93 all
right so now this move comes with tempo
so while this is an awkward looking move
now I could I could take this guy out
I'm giving up my good Bishop but I am
getting a pawn these guys are doubled
not isolated quite yet but they're
certainly backward and I don't know that
they're really targetable since my
bishop is controlling b8
but you know at the same time where is
he even going
I don't think I have any worry of this
night bobbing my butt my bishop controls
here I'm considering age three at this
point age three and Bishop takes Knight
are my two candidate moves
I'm gonna take the night I don't see a
reason not to and oh that must have been
a mouse slip you know except that one
yeah it's definitely a mouse loop so my
follow up is not gonna be to grab that
pond I want to make sure I preserve my
bishop
so he's controlling being I don't want
to have any pressure against these guys
he's going nowhere
it's pawn in a six so I'm just looking
to castle I may even want to consider
King to d2 just to bring him a little
bit closer if need be he can be around
to defend my doubled be pawns but
certainly have to be a bit cautious of
Knight jumping in here
these guys offset one another c3 and f6
so king d2 rook h2 a one
hmmm I think it's worthwhile to do that
he's just I'm just not gonna move on
I'm bishop here then I'll grab the pawn
because maybe a five is gonna be a pain
and that pun lives bishop d8 I just grab
okay he's got to go and do I really need
to worry about doubled pawns no let's
just double rooks here maybe now I could
consider Knight to e1 if I wanted to
preserve my structure and regroup the
knight to d3 so even if these guys are
attacked I'll be there to defend with my
King which is ideal because he's close
to the center and he serves a useful
role on just defending potential attacks
but it's quite difficult to even see how
black gets into a position to attack my
weaknesses whereas these guys will fall
well at least the a6 pawn in probably a7
I don't see how you defend that okay I
think II five is being prepped I think I
should first secure this square again
he's going nowhere so in the event of
Bishop takes pawn takes e5 I can take
twice one or two squares
mmm I'll just go to I don't see any
great difference between these two
squares we're about even on time I think
in some lines if I'm castled Bishop h2
takes away a potential flight square for
my King but that's not the case here I'm
doing this move more for like I don't
want h5h for with tempo some tempo type
moves like that I think it's finally
time to just crash through on this pawn
and get to the seventh rank and I could
even consider b5 and then I'll have a
past seep on a connected past seep on
I don't see any reason to not follow
through and grab that guy I'm gonna do
it on the seventh ring so this bishops
now pinned so I'm threatening Bishop to
d6 threatening the rook right now
Bishop to d6
I'm up to pawns now okay simplifying
even more probably have to get out of
the pin I'm seeing the road to victory
here it's King well there's gonna be
many at this point but I think King c3
there's no fear of any passed pawns
being created by force on the black side
my rook is ideally placed I'm thinking
about just V 5 V 5 takes and then King V
4 and then grab the pawn this Bishop has
to be super annoying
just get my King involved there might be
a five at this point yeah there is boo
why did I consider that more
um I should have not even allowed that
like I don't even I don't even want this
rook to think about getting active
all right well I shouldn't have allowed
that this is what I'm gonna do
King 85 B 4 and then I'm taking on this
square I think B 4 would be a good move
here let's see if my opponent comes up
with it okay now my bishop is back to
life I think that was an instance where
black does well to keep the tension
because now he's back to controlling b8
so I will take this guy out I thought
better was before although no I could
take it and then return to c3 to defend
b2 I'm just trying to make sure that
this rook doesn't get active I don't
want any of blacks pieces to get active
and this rook is doing a good job in
restricting the King the bishop
restricts the rook and before my Bishop
can get locked out with f4 let's just
make sure he'll still be seen his
presence will be felt on the black side
Bishop to e5 King takes b5
c6 c7 King c6
I have my pawn on c7 though the rook is
no longer defending these squares and
cutting the King off less than 20
okay I don't see any reason not to grab
this guy
and any trades are going to be winds
anything better than that
hmm I don't think so push my pond king a
six and run the other pond or maybe not
so fast
I'll go b4 first King a5 and then before
came here oh there's gonna be a passed
pawn no there isn't
okay now this no I don't I could just
block threatening well not me because my
pawns pinned
now it's close to me push I'm getting a
queen next where's the mate
somewhere close all right my opponent
lost on time let's go back good game the
first concern I had here was well
you know what I'm going to be well this
is what you'll have to be content with
it seems if you're going to exchange
Queens like this I will be getting in
the b5 move by force or making your
Knights deployment a bit awkward hmm
like if you're trying to stop b5 with a
six a six be for still happens Knight d7
I can still play b5 because you're not
in time to get the rook out of the pin
on the egg on the a e8 square on the a
file so the another approach that you
could consider is Queen c7 on Queen c7 I
have a bishop to f4 Queen takes Bishop
Queen takes pawn and I get the rook next
so you could go with Queen c7 Bishop f4
Queen to c8 it looks passive but you
know I'll have to move my queen again
before I get this b5 idea in and in the
meantime you could try to prep an e5
advance that is another direction to go
in once I got to this position right
here well I felt pretty good your pieces
are well placed over it well I don't
know well placed but they seem natural
enough right Knight f6 Bishop outside
your pawn chain as well your knight is
certainly the awkward one though and
that's that's kind of tough there after
castles I take that night out and the
alternative is what exactly instead of
castling if you're moving the knight to
be it I could take him and then play
rook takes a seven it's kind of tough I
don't know nothing is standing out to me
that's so great on the black side and
you like it like a certain plan having
difficulty coming up with something good
for the black side yeah I don't
the e5 is the only break you could try
to look for but I have to go to control
over with my Bishop Knight and pawn and
these guys they just turn out to be too
passive this has to be really annoying
the bishop controlling on b8 so I think
it's all kind of coming back to maybe
the decision to trade Queens or not hmm
I think I think you kind of have to go
in this direction I'm not certain but
it's certainly not certain but it's
certainly I'm not certain but it it
feels like maybe can't be taking the
Queen like this this is very good if I
can get the b5 moving you know I'll no
longer what sort of situation would I
find myself in one where I don't no
longer have to work with doubled pawns
not that they're a great liability but
you know I eliminate it I no longer
working with double puns and I have free
play for my rook yeah I think I think
Queen c7 is is going to be the other one
to be considering it's really a long
road ahead as soon as you get in this
position with without the Queen's I'm
not sure if maybe Ponte so looking at a
different now pawn takes your bishops
dead I get my knight in to be 5 and then
c4 and who knows what other great
squares he could be jumping into a5 or
d6 sometime so yeah you have the bishop
here but it's not really going to be
enough with these rooks there's just
nothing you could do they were so weak
you couldn't even defend them so and I'm
not sure if it really even matters at
this point I don't know that there was a
great follow up again I think it's
really coming back to as far as the
Queen trade I would have I just it's
already it's already lost its way lost
at this point but it still
keeping the tension though I guess
eventually you're gonna have to make a
capture after b4 and he's secure this is
back on tough position I mean unless I'm
screwing up here it's it's going to be
it should be when okay and let me just
look at this last pawn structure thing
pawn takes oh yeah for some reason I was
thinking you're going to get a passed
pawn
and oh well I guess you could if you
take with the F pun and then I recapture
you could push f4 rh4 he'll be passed
I'll be there to stop him but there is a
way I think earlier in the game I was
saying there's no way that by force
black can be forcing through a passed
pawn I'm mistaken with that with this
particular structure so after G for mate
in maybe in some more critical positions
this is something that will play a key
role not the case here but with G for F
takes G if you're taking with your F
pawn preserving your age pawn then it
looks like you're going to get be
getting a passed pawn since you're
controlling h4 I can't meet F takes G
for with H for myself okay
now good getting good game let me close
out of this one
you